[Music]
hello and welcome to the week in 60
minutes brought to you by spectator tv
and broadcast on thursday january 20th
i'm kate andrews the spectators
economics editor and your host this week
on this week's show
redwall tory mps turned on boris johnson
with the sioux gray report now due next
week can his premiership survive katie
balls and james forsyth will join me
we know what the prime minister's
critics think but what about his
supporters how can they still say he's
up to the job i'll speak to tory mp
marcus fish
douglas murray says in this week's
magazine that there's little to show for
the 11 years of conservative rule
johnson's attempts to woo voters with
populist policies just won't cut it he
says he'll be on to explain
then we'll turn to kovid it looks like
omicron has hit its peak but we'll dig
into the details with michael simmons
the spectator's data journalist who will
run us through the latest numbers then
i'll speak to dr ellen brooks pollock
she sits on the spy m group and will
talk to us about the modeling process
finally in his column this week rory
sutherland says drinking in the office
really isn't so bad he'll tell us why
before we get going if you enjoy
spectator tv remember to subscribe to
our youtube channel click the red
subscribe button at the bottom of this
video and tap the bell icon to make sure
you never miss an episode
and why not subscribe to the spectators
magazine too
you can get 12 weeks of the magazine in
print and online along with a 20 pound
amazon voucher for just 12 pounds go to
spectator dot co dot uk forward slash tv
offer to take it up
yesterday it seemed like boris johnson
might be facing a no-confidence vote
imminently his red wall mps that's those
representing seats that were previously
labor strongholds turned on him after
weeks of revelations about downing
street parties during lockdown
but might the pm be safe for now anyway
i'm joined by katie balls he wrote this
week's cover piece and our political
editor james forsyth
katie in this week's cover piece you
write about how red walt tory mps have
turned on the prime minister can you
briefly run us through what's happened
the past few days
yes so i think there was an expectation
that this week would be almost a quiet
week in between the drama of last week
when there are new revelations about
boris johnson and partygate his
admission that he attended a dining
street party and now that weight to the
sue grey report into parties but there
was quite a lot of panic on tuesday
amongst the whips in 10 dining street
and because they suddenly got word that
lots of letters could be going in and
actually a confidence vote could happen
this week now
the reason they thought they weren't
going to hit 54 this week was that
ultimately it was mainly
long time boris johnson critics
a handful of perhaps scottish tories and
therefore they thought that the main
bulk of the party is not going to move
until they see the report but actually
the 2019 intake and many of them are red
wool um seats in terms of their their
constituencies they have got together
and what's been dubbed the pork pie plot
owned to um the host of the meeting or
one of one of those involved persevered
to and has a seat which is linked to
pork pies not also a red wall seat it's
quite a weak joke but um the reason it's
important was around 20 of these mps met
up they had a secret ballot to see how
many had already put their letters in
that was about half and more planned to
do so and that led to retaliation by the
whips office by the government and and
really
a defection eventually of one tory mp to
labor was interesting as the reason
we're not talking on a day of confidence
votes i think that defection by
christian wakefield has calmed things
down slightly but if you step away from
this what you have is a situation where
the very mps that boris johnson and once
you saw his the future of his
premiership those red wall seats that he
staked so much on and are the ones that
are actually now turning against him and
really leading the fight to oust him
from 10 downing street
and james how is the prime minister
standing today to pick up on a point
that katie just made that you yourself
have also written about he's in a
strangely better place now isn't he that
there's been this defection of a red
wall mp christian wakeford
so the the defection stopped the
plotting because it it got the tory's
tribal um sense going again uh they were
rowdier in support of boris johnson at
pmq's and they have been recently where
they've been
conspicuously quiet uh but i think that
was largely because they were shouting
at christian wakeford who had uh who had
left their benches to go and sit behind
kierstarma
on the labour side i think what
christian wakefield has done is he means
that tory mps are now reversing to what
was plan a which was to wait for the su
gray report to come out uh and then send
their letters in i think there are a
chunk of tory mps quite large in number
probably not large enough on their own
to tip it over the 54 mark who are
prepared to uh who have essentially made
up their mind to send a letter in as
soon as the great report comes out
almost regardless of what it says
one of them said to me you know that's
the right thing to do because you must
have due process not mob justice so i
mean the prime minister's the moment of
vulnerability of the prime minister now
is when this great report comes out
there is intense speculation in
whitehall about uh how bad it is going
to be for the prime minister downing
street had been very confident that that
it was that it was going to be something
from which they could launch a fight
back and i think sue gray is a sore
servant she's not going to want to write
and it's not her remit to write a report
that brings down the prime minister but
i think this delay in the report coming
out uh it was you know down street were
expecting it towards the end of this
week it's now not coming out until next
week i don't think that is an
encouraging sign for them katie why is
it that 2019 mps and red wall mps in
particular are turning on the prime
minister
i think there's a few factors i think
the
most obvious is just small majorities
you have a situation where lots of those
seats particularly in the red walls so
the midlands and north and are you know
a couple of hundred christian wakefield
who defected his um majority was you
know just under 400 around 400.
and
therefore i think when these mps start
to look at the polls um you know some
polls putting labor uh 11 points ahead
and they start to get very nervous they
don't think they have the luxury of some
of these mps and more traditional
tourist seats to wait and see how things
happen and they're also fairly new
obviously um they've only been in
parliament for you know a handful of
years now about two years so when they
get that voter backlash they have less
to compare it to and that's a lot of
people say the voter backlash on this is
bad um there was a poll um just this
week um which came out which said you
know in the red wall on current polling
where an election held tomorrow they
would lose all but a handful of seats so
just keep a very small number that you
can to one hand and i think that is
clearly making people very nervous you
all have to have a situation where i
think these mps are much more
independent partly because many of them
did not actually expect to be elected in
2019 um and for that reason you didn't
really see um cchq putting in their
favorite candidates in some of these
places and you know the traditional
route of former special advisor turned
mp and they're much more likely to be
local activists and i think as one um
whit put to me when they're trying to
explain how this flock is quite tricky
for them is they said
in their view that lots of these mps are
not tories they are brexiteers who ran
for the conservative party
um and that means that there is less of
a probably a patience with you know
sticking with and what's good for the
the tory brand in that sense james you
write in the magazine this week that
tory mps want to see major changes in
downing street and you mentioned that a
number 10 plan is to try to bring back
linton crosby the famed campaigner who
won david cameron his majority in 2015
and has also worked with boris johnson
in the past would that be enough a
change at the very top to make tory mps
happy or are they going to want to see
more
i think the presence of linton crosby
would reassure a lot of tory mps
one cabinet minister who's kind of loyal
to boris johnson likened uh him to boris
johnson to a kind of a bright but
disorganized pupil who needs a kind of
tutor to kind of stand over him and make
sure he does his homework and get him
through his exams and they see linton
crosby as that kind of figure i mean
they also think that lincoln cross
people kind of you know to use one of
his phrases get the barnacles off the
boat um get and also put an end to this
situation where boris johnson's attitude
to his advisors has always been a bit
like british foreign policy towards
europe in the 19th century he wants to
maintain a balance of power among them
so that no one faction is is dominant
and he likes that because that means
that you know he is ultimately the
casting vote and everyone has to look to
him for for a decision and i think tory
mps wants an end to those competing
agendas and they think that lyndon
crosby would not i don't think their
rights in this would not come into
downing street unless he had that kind
of authority
so we know what johnson's critics think
but what about his supporters how do
they defend the prime minister's actions
i was joined yesterday evening by marcus
fish a conservative mp who is still
backing the prime minister
marcus thanks so much for joining
spectator tv
so some of your colleagues have become
more vocal in the past few days about
their feelings about the prime minister
specifically that he needs to resign
most of your colleagues have tried to
remain silent on the matter putting
their heads down not going one way or
the other but you're joining us today to
give a robust defense of the prime
minister
what would you say is your top line
i am a supporter of the prime minister i
don't want to in any way minimize uh
what may have happened or
how people might feel about that and i
know it's irritating it's irritated me
it's irritated it's more than irritated
a lot of people
but the fact is the country has
some really big challenges as we come
out of the pandemic and i certainly
think that the prime minister
deserves our support
trying to get his operation into a
better state
and one that is really fit for those
challenge for addressing those
challenges
that are so important to ordinary
people's lives up and down the country
you talk about him needing to get
operations in order him needing to sort
some things out is your support
conditional say on reorganization of
number 10 or an additional apology or
the sue gray report or is it
unconditional a pragmatic approach that
you want certain policies achieved in
the future and you think he's the person
to get them over the line
everyone will be interested to see what
the sugree report
says
and
to be
clear that there are any lessons that
need to be learned from that have been
learned
and
that you know new new structures if
they're needed are implemented i do
think going forward we need to focus
on a
uh sort of
conservative approach to
life after the pandemic i think we need
to focus on reforms that that can
increase the supply of goods and
services as a way of addressing the cost
of living pressures that are coming
through
and i do think that we need a new team
around the prime minister to be able to
be credible in delivering that
you speak of a staff overhaul but i
think it will still concern people this
idea that the prime minister needs
multiple people around him new people
around him to inform him of a simple
fact whether or not a party is going on
in front of his own eyes it doesn't
speak very highly of his judgment if he
needs a cohort of people to inform him
whether or not the warm white wine the
food on the tables the dozens of people
around him socializing classify as a
party or not
i think we need to understand what the
facts of the matter are and that that's
the whole point of the sugray report so
i would rather sort of wait and see what
happens
there
um i do think you know
no one is perfect and
no one's judgment is perfect all of the
time
but i do think
that the prime minister is
somebody who is able to communicate very
well with people and i think we need to
give him the chance to
do that and to set out
the path that he wants to
take us out of the pandemic on
and i i think most people in the country
are probably going to
be more focused on
what the future holds for them
rather than the particular details of
something that happened
coming up for two years ago
in the height of a pandemic which is
thankfully um receiving into the past
behind us in part because of
the
the very
good actions that the prime minister has
championed along the way whether it's on
vaccines
and getting that program organized the
unlocking program
that means that our economy is in better
shape now than almost any other economy
in the world and that gives us a good
platform on which to build i think
people in the country would be
would actually look pretty aghast at
tories fighting with each other
when we should be focused on the future
as you mentioned this government hasn't
seized on many of the opportunities of
brexit yet and i know that you were also
a strong opponent of the vaccine
passport scheme which ended up being
ushered in under boris johnson albeit
now is going to be shelved when plan b
measures expire next week you and your
colleague david davis have both broadly
speaking been lined up on these issues
but of course david davis took a
different perspective on the prime
minister's future in the house of
commons today
why is it that you have decided to split
from that perspective and defend the
prime minister when as you point out
yourself he's actually disappointed you
on quite a few fronts over the past few
years since he's had the opportunity to
make real change
well i i do believe his heart is in the
right place on that clearly the pandemic
has been a massive
issue in terms of sucking all of the
bandwidth out of government in a whole
range of areas
um and now as an opportunity to to set
out that
that
conservative path to making use of our
freedoms and
making use of it in a way
that is beneficial to the people of this
this country and i think that a further
distraction
of you know
um
uh different candidates being championed
by different people it would be a very
messy situation for
for many months and actually i think we
are better off
um sticking with the
with with with the date who we came with
and sorting it out and sorting it out
for people up and down the country
uh last question to you marcus uh what
would it take to convince you otherwise
or change your mind if the prime
minister were found to have known about
the party on the 20th of may he has
insisted that he had no prior knowledge
that there was going to be a party
taking place do you think then he should
resign
i think we need to
appreciate what the situation was at
that time he was only barely a few weeks
out of hospital
and i just simply don't don't know what
what emails he might have been seeing or
not seeing or or
what or what he was being advised but it
is it is conceivable that his judgment
wasn't in tip-top shape at that point in
time and i think that most people
thinking back to that time
will appreciate that that was
um that that that was a potentially
um
difficult situation for him and
everybody else i'm not defending in any
way the
um i think
somewhat pure our behavior of um
what seems to be
to have been going on in um number 10
among some of the
staff
and i think that they should have had
more
more of a mind to what people were
sacrificing around the country at that
time but would you agree that over the
past few weeks when the prime minister
has been insisting to the house of
commons that he had no knowledge of
parties taking place that he has been in
a sound state of mind while doing that
i would hope so yeah
marcus thank you for joining spectator
tv
with tory poll numbers collapsing number
10 has a grand plan to win voters back
and they're calling it operation red
meat unveiling policies like freezing
the bbc license fee to try to get their
supporters back on side in this week's
magazine douglas murray says he's not
being fooled after 11 years of
conservative rule there's little to show
for it to discuss he joins me on the
show now
douglas as always thank you for joining
spectator tv you write in the magazine
this week about operation red meat boris
johnson's plan to save his premiership
tell us what you make of it
yes operation red meat is the report
that the prime minister is going to try
to overcome
the travails that he has gone through in
recent weeks
by throwing his
voter base some red meat
some
tough tory policies uh that will
hopefully dampen any uh leadership
questions around him dampen uh all of
the discontent and remind the great uh
conservative voter base of why they need
boris johnson more than ever
um
i've been looking at a lot of these
policies
and they're around immigration the bbc
as you say real red meat for the base
do you think it's working or do you
think he's just reminding his core base
of what he hasn't done for two and a
half years
yeah that's a very important point
exactly see as i say in the column my
own view is that there's no reason why
if you haven't done something from day
one you're suddenly going to start doing
it in year three
uh and i think the conservative voters
now as with previous conservative
governments a right to be skeptical
about this
um
as you said there's the bbc what does it
consist of so far nadine dory is
announcing this week there will be a
freeze on the license fee uh do you
remember the beginning of this uh
government we had uh talk of charles
moore no less our own colleague uh
taking over as chairman of the bbc um
they didn't manage with that they didn't
manage anything comparable uh and we've
got this i wouldn't call it red meat i'd
call it rather plain fare
of saying that we will have a freeze in
the license fee um i'm not i'm not sure
by the way the bbc is a particularly
good one to run on on that actually the
bbc has um unlike saying american media
has has has a lot of discontents from
both political sides but has still got a
significant amount of trust in the
country including among some or many
conservative voters so i'm not sure
that's the best one to go on but yes
other red meat issues include of course
immigration boris johnson's now going to
have to pretend that he's going to do
something about an issue he hasn't done
anything about for the last two years or
more um he's going to have to talk tough
on an issue which he'd hoped clearly as
i said in the magazine once before he'd
hoped would sort of slide by beneath the
radar boris johnson's hope was that
hundreds and in the end more than a
thousand people coming illegally across
the channel every day
was just not going to be of significant
enough interest to detain the attentions
of the british people he was wrong on
that uh but he still hasn't developed
policy but we already see this week
again a little bit of operation red meat
perhaps
talk of sending in
the military to deal with the situation
in the channel uh sending in the royal
navy the army perhaps the raf in due
course uh i can't help smiling about
this of course because it's so
incredibly transparent uh it's the sort
of tough talk that some conservatives
like to engage in in the hope that it'll
almost sexually thrill their voters and
of course actually it it doesn't i think
the conservative voters are not uh what
boris johnson thinks they are i think
they are as i think he's making the same
mistakes i say in the column that
theresa may made uh which is when she
got that rather
disconcerting sense of disconnect from
the voter base suddenly makes a
presumption that the conservative voter
base is both ugly and stupid
and i think they're neither um but uh
boris johnson is going the same route
it's a great mistake
you haven't always had such criticism
for the prime minister you once wrote
that he was the only politician of his
generation who can make people feel good
what do you think's changed
yeah i i stick by that i i've always
maintained that
that he has qualities that almost on the
unheard of in his generation certainly
unparalleled in his generation uh it
used to be the case again you might say
the referendum took some of this out of
out of it but uh it used to be the case
that if you mentioned boris's name in
the country first of all first name
terms like kylie like madonna like other
sort of celebrities
boris always if you say boris's name to
people ah boris there is a sort of um
lifting of the spirits the sense of
holiday as i've said before nobody ever
said ah teresa
no one ever said ah john good old john
major um it never happened the point is
is that boris had an unusual quality in
politics
but as i mentioned in this week's column
that seems to have faded i'm reminded of
the case of michael barrymore after the
body was found in his pool it wasn't
that michael barrymore's talent
disappeared it wasn't that we didn't
still remember that he was a man capable
of making us laugh it's just that the
laughter died
and something similar has happened in
recent weeks and days with boris johnson
it's the period in which the laughter
has died
we know that he was once able to
entertain
but the question remains over whether he
can govern
and some people would say that the
answer to that question is now in
well i'm curious as to what you would
say douglas i think it's quite clear
that you are disappointed with where his
premiership has taken the country so far
i think it's a damning but very
revealing point that you make that the
laughter has died and and once the
laughter dies you know that's when you
know things are really very grim
do you think it's time that he threw in
the table
well um it's very interesting watching
the uh stunt which is the best way to
put it on what david davis did at prime
minister's questions this week a very
striking thing to do uh of actually
calling for the prime minister's
resignation in the house of commons on
his own benches uh some people would say
well that's david davis being david
davis um however it's it's a serious uh
advance really in the movement of
dissatisfaction within the conservative
party here's the thing that will keep
keep boris johnson in place for the time
being it simply isn't clear that there
is any obvious success and now members
of the conservative party and others who
i speak to say to me well douglas it was
the same before nobody ever arrived in
office fully formed you know even even
the greats like margaret thatcher didn't
arrive into office fully formed as
margaret thatcher so you always take a
bit of a risk on it as it were with a
leader here's the problem though
it's very hard to see
how the conservatives could first of all
engage in a leadership battle at this
stage if they're going to do it they'll
they should do it soon by the way i mean
there's no point in doing this say a
year before the election
um so the first but the first thing is
that in any case
is the country really
up for another conservative party
leadership contest you know there is
this pretence that the conservative
party is this brutally efficient machine
but anyone who's seen it up close knows
that it's much more like a sausage
making factory you really don't want to
see how it works up close
the second thing is of course
is there a successor and i would say at
the moment that the answer to that is
very clearly no
there is no obvious successor to boris
johnson
uh there are many impressive people
around him and indeed on his benches i
would say the conservative party has
a significant amount of talent including
talent from recent intakes uh it's a
very striking contrast with the labour
party where effectively if you go below
the the level of kierstama you get to
just um
an extraordinary array of people some of
whom you can't believe are allowed out
in public let alone alone into the house
of commons uh so but it's a different
level of talent on the conservative
benches they have got very significant
um talented figures however are any of
them yet in a position
first of all to take over the reigns of
the most important office in the land
and secondly to either keep or grow
that important electoral advance that
boris johnson did make in 2019
could can anyone honestly say that rishi
sunak for instance um is going to
satisfy uh crucial voters in the red
wall i i'm not sure about that um are
any of the other contenders none of them
spring to mind so i think for the time
being it's likely that johnson will hold
on simply because it's not clear what
the alternative is there is no king or
queen over the water there is no person
absolutely ready to step forward but
as i say that doesn't rule out the
possibility that that there might be a
challenge because of course never forget
that there's an important rule in
politics which is only one thing unites
every single member of the house of
commons and that is the belief misguided
though it almost always is but at some
point history will call and it will be
them
douglas while i have you here let me ask
you one more question going past boris
johnson and his two and a half years in
office and looking more generally at the
conservative party what do you make of
their now 11 years in power
somehow they've had control that long
and yet we've ended up with the biggest
tax burden in 71 years
yes um
there's really only one selling point
that conservatives have after 11 years
of conservative majority government and
that is this
they haven't been labor
and that's it
that's almost the sum total of their
abilities and their boasts to date
now of course we had the five years of
the coalition government and david
cameron could always say well we had
this ball and chain around our ankles
called the liberal democrat party
specifically nick clegg that is a
significant ball and chain to have to
suffer along with as you shuffle through
the business of government but then
there was a period in which david
cameron did have a majority there was a
period where theresa may had a majority
she of course blew a majority
but we still had a conservative majority
government we now have a situation with
boris johnson for as i say over two
years where we have not just an atc tory
majority but also a crisis that he could
have used and at the end of that crisis
and that 80-seat majority as i say in
the column and as you well know uh the
question is
have we been governed by conservatives
and the answer really is no we've been
governed by not labor we've been
governed by not corbyn
we have historic levels of public
borrowing we have tax rises national
insurance rises with the old trick the
old gordon brown trick of pretending
that the national insurance rise isn't
really a tax rise all of the things
we've seen many times before and what is
the one flagship policy of this
government
cop 26
the promise that if we try hard enough
we won't have any electricity by the end
of the decade
uh the promise that our our electricity
bills our fuel bills are all going to
keep rising all to get to an un
unsustainable impossible goal
but so the one thing that we have really
got in policy terms from boris johnson
in his prime ministership so far is
greenery uh a sort of particularly in my
form ridiculous form of greenery as i
say in my column this week we voted
conservative as a country in 2019 and we
got the member for brighton pavilion
that is of course caroline lucas
um so that's the the problem
the conservative voter base will feel as
they often do completely let down by a
conservative government conservative
governments are masters at letting down
their own publics their own voters
but as i say we'll end up always with
this question who else and i would
expect by the way as i mentioned in the
column that operation red meat will also
include a significant dollop of
you thought jeremy corbyn was bad wait
till you see what comrade kirstar would
do if he was in office
i'm not sure that that's a threat
that the natural voter base of the
conservative party let alone the wider
country is going to be all that
terrified about
in due course
well there you have it viewers douglas
murray's take on the not labour party
douglas as always thanks for joining us
it's a great pleasure
and now to covet the government has
announced that it's scrapping plan b
restrictions because it looks like
omicron is receding models used by the
government in december showed that we
could be seeing around 2 500 deaths a
day at this point the actual figure is
closer to 200. why is there such a
disparity
michael simmons the spectator's data
journalist joins us now to talk about
the latest coveted figures
michael thanks for joining us on
spectator tv so what's the latest on the
covet data thanks for having me on kate
well what we've seen uh this week the
really important kind of data that's out
this week is the case numbers and we're
seeing something that was originally a
trend in south africa and then appeared
to be a trend in london and now it seems
to be a trend in the uk as a whole is
that cases are falling almost as quickly
as they initially rose
and some people are saying that this is
just because people are testing less if
you get a positive test on a lateral
flow for example you might not go and
report it online and now you're not
actually asked to take a pcr either yep
well there's certainly um reports of
this as you say that um and sage have
spoke about this as well that there
might be
different factors affecting the test
numbers
as you say you no longer need to confirm
a lateral flow test with a pcr test so
might it just be that cases are not
actually falling it's just that less
people are testing but actually
yesterday we had really crucial data
from the office of national statistics
and they released the coronavirus
infection survey which is really the
gold standard of measuring um infection
numbers and true case numbers and that
showed um in england and also in all
other parts of the uk that omicron
seemed to peak just at the beginning of
january so it does look like the fall in
cases is real and we are seeing that
across the country
really interesting stuff but of course
cases are not the most important data
point it's hospitalizations and deaths
that we most crucially have to track so
what are the metrics looking like there
so um early on um in december uh sage
were warning and that
there was potential to see between 600
and six thousand deaths a day around
this time and that was backed up by
modeling from work where they looked at
different scenarios for the severity um
of omicron compared to delta and those
scenarios were for 10 percent 20
50 and 100 in other words as severe as
delta and and we can see when we um plot
the actual daily deaths they're nowhere
near even the lowest scenario the 10
scenario which shed by now we should be
seeing a peak of deaths at around 600 a
day but in reality we're in the sort of
low 200s and it's also important to say
that those um def's numbers um are
actually probably a bit inflated because
of the amount of incidental covert cases
we have so a lot of those deaths will be
people who ha have had covered when they
died but they didn't necessarily die of
covert
and michael let me just pick you up on
that last point because if we go back a
year and a half into this pandemic there
was a great debate about whether or not
people were in hospital or sadly dying
with coveter of covet but that gap was
quite small if in april 2020 you were in
hospital with kovud you were very likely
suffering from covid omicron seems to
have really changed that dynamic hasn't
it i know you've been following figures
in london for people who are testing
positive for covid in hospitals in
london but that doesn't necessarily mean
that they're very sick with the virus
anymore does it yeah absolutely so again
this was something that was seen in
early south african data and then as
omicron was seated in london we saw it
in london as well which is that the
incidental hospital cases so people who
are in coveted for being primarily
treated sorry for people who are in
hospital being primarily treated for
something other than covert but happen
to have covid that number was kind of
flat until omicron came along and now
that proportion has really just shot up
and and we had data out this morning
that showed in london it's now as high
as 60 percent and in england as a whole
it's reached 48 which is the highest
it's ever been
wow
finally michael you wrote a piece last
week about how the actual data compared
to the modeling that the government was
using how do the models from december
and the actual data compare
uh yeah so um i spoke earlier about the
uh the defs modeling um from work we
also have hospitalization um models from
work and again it's those four scenarios
um for different severity 10 20 50 and
100
and if we plot the actual
hospitalizations against those scenarios
the only one that's really tracking
close to um reality is the 10 scenario
but that leaves questions about and how
these models were derived because no one
has really ever suggested that omicron
is only 10 as severe as delta and indeed
the latest estimates from the uk health
security agency suggests it's more
likely around 50 percent
yes they've been using that 50 mark and
if you look at that 50
you know the the modeling's off the
scale compared to the real world data
isn't it absolutely
michael thanks so much for joining me
what is spy m and how does it come up
with its models i'm joined now by dr
ellen brooks pollock an infectious
disease modeler from the university of
bristol who sits on the spyam group
which advises the government
dr brooks pollock thank you so much for
joining us on spectator tv to start can
you tell us about the modeling group
that advises the government what exactly
does it do
yeah so
it's called it's called spy m which
stands for the scientific pandemic
influenza group
on modeling and it's a subgroup of sage
the scientific advisory group for
emergencies and it deals specifically
with infectious disease modeling so
there's a few different aspects to that
some of it is
scenario modelling other other parts of
it is
trying to say what's going on with the
pandemic at the moment uh for example
estimating important epidemiological
parameters like maybe the mortality rate
the transmission rate
um
and
other parts are kind of specific
questions maybe tailored to for example
care homes or schools so um kind of
targeted targeted modelling
can you tell us a bit more about this
and maybe walk us through the covert
modeling process what are you looking at
specifically when you're trying to model
how a virus will behave in the future
yeah so um an infectious disease model
is basically a mathematical description
of how disease spreads in a population
and at the core of all these epidemic
models is the transmission of infection
between individuals so
that could be really simple i could have
an infectious disease model
with two people in it say me and you
and
um
if
for example if there's a one in six
chance that i'll pass it on to pass an
infection onto you if i'm infected i
could then run this model lots of times
and then come up with
the number of times that you get
infected and the number of times that
you don't get infected
um and so that that would be a perfectly
reasonable infectious disease model but
and basically the models that we use
are based on that kind of models apart
from they don't just involve two people
they involve everyone in the country and
we include lots of other complexities
like
different rates of contact between
children and adults different rates of
symptomatic infection different rates of
severe disease
lots of other factors that might be
important in covert transmission but
really at its core it's this
transmission between two individuals
and how do you decide what to input into
those models who makes those calls
well
i mean infectious disease modeling as a
as a branch of mathematics has been
around now since
um well for decades but um it really
kind of came into its own in the 1980s
with hiv and aids and so a lot of the
theory that we've been that we work with
has been developed over over many years
in terms of what's important and what's
not important for a particular disease
that really comes from data as much as
possible
so for example for covid it's obviously
um important that we included
asymptomatic transmission so
transmission from people who didn't have
symptoms
and so
uh
what you try and do with your models is
include as much data as possible
and where you don't have data you try
and be as agnostic as possible so you
don't assign
a probability of
associated with that particular thing
there's an infinite amount of modeling
that one could do for something like
covid so how do you decide how to narrow
that down and who ultimately is making
the call about what you are going to
model
well
so that's really um
a mixture of different a different a
mixture of different processes
um so there's some policy ask so
there's some decision making that needs
to be done then the
sage and the spam secretariat they
transform policy asks into a question
that can be modeled that can be answered
with modelling
um
and so there's that's one route another
route is
can you say sorry just to clarify
when you say sorry just to clarify when
you say policy asks you mean officials
in whitehall want certain questions
answered and they put them to spy m and
the sage groups yes
and then uh the other route is
through working with clinicians and
working with public health officials and
um
just
kind of the other general
general roots through the scientific
discourse other questions come up and
we work on those because they because we
consider them important or somebody
considers them important so
it's a combination of
policy asks and big scientific questions
which are communicated within the
scientific community in general
does sage sage acts independently from
government and yet there's as we've just
been discussing a lot of overlap between
the requests and what's being returned
does sage ever get requests about being
asked to input something or model
something and actually think to
themselves
that's not the right question to be
asking that doesn't quite add up that's
too optimistic that's too pessimistic we
don't feel like we're being asked for a
whole range of answers here and then
might they take it upon themselves to
model it anyway or are you only
responding to the requests of officials
or clinicians or public health officials
no so absolutely the um
the modeling is that's done is a
combination of
as i mentioned the secretariat they
translate things into
modelling questions and sometimes that's
an iterative process absolutely things
get changed
and then
the kind of researcher or
scientist-driven questions um they come
forward as well and
i mean one thing that's really important
is there's not just one model and one
group of modelers that are responding to
these questions
um i mean spien consists of about 50
infectious disease modelers and
i don't know maybe 10 different
institutions
and so often people have different
approaches and have asked different
questions and taken done things in a
different way and so that plurality of
opinion is really important for making
sure that we don't end up just with one
answer to one question
at the spectator we've published some
criticism of the modeling saying that
it's often been too pessimistic i think
you've actually responded to some of
that do you think that's an unfair
assessment
well
so
models and themselves are not
not pessimistic or optimistic they're
often designed to do
a particular thing and the models that
make the headlines of
really just a very very small sample of
the models that are discussed at spy
eminen and in other forums um i mean as
you can imagine it things get complex
very quickly as soon as you start
incorporating different probabilities
and different uh different aspects of
people's behavior
and so actually it's it's
almost impossible or very difficult to
predetermine what the output would be so
you put in everything you think you
believe
to be correct and the data that you
believe to be correct and you don't
really have any say in what what the
output is
um
i mean though
even though as i mentioned there'd be
many models that been developed during
the pandemic
um
and they certainly haven't only
contributed to
evidence supporting
increased restrictions
models also for example contributed to
the evidence that supported the
introduction of support bubbles where
single person households could join with
other households during the lockdown
they also contributed to
evidence behind schools reopening
um and lifting of restrictions as well
but um yeah they tend like tend not to
be as headline grabbing but um
absolutely models have gone in both ways
that's an important point about the
headlines which i want to come back to
but first i think we we saw the clinch
point of this last month when the sage
scenarios that were published published
showed that deaths by now would be
anything between 500 to 5000 a day the
actual figures look closer to 200 and
even this is potentially overstated due
to the rise in patients who have had
coveted and then sadly died from other
ailments i absolutely take the point
that models are not meant to be
predictions but surely given the
expertise and the brain power behind the
models they should somewhat line up with
real world outcomes
otherwise how can you make the case for
them
i mean um some of the models um
actually under predicted total numbers
of uh total numbers of deaths by this
point so it's absolutely not true that
they all
were an overestimate
are those in the public domain they are
they are yes in fact i think they're on
the spectator website as well if you um
select but i mean it's all about
how severe
um how severe omicron is compared to
delta and when these when these models
were done
uh it was it was very unclear from the
data what it was and so a variety of
scenarios were looked at
and
it's obviously excellent news that we're
on the lower end of those of those
numbers
because looking at the spectator data
hub right now
in terms of hospitalization
beds occupied and deaths the actual
outcome is far far below anything that
was released by the sage models in
december i think to your point about
headlines as well
it gives the false sense perhaps that
these are predictions but then of course
this the fact that they're presented as
predictions heavily influences public
policy
well
i mean policy
so the data that goes into these models
changes all the time so looking at a
fixed
point in time of when they were done in
december isn't necessarily reflective of
what they were i can absolutely send you
um links of models where things were
under predicted as well they're
they're um i don't know
the spectator
i'm sure throughout the pandemic that
there have been those moments but i
think that december
those december sage models compared to
what actually happened and the real
world data we were seeing from south
africa is what has brought this whole
question of modeling finally to the
forefront
the fact that the not predictions but
the models were were so
more extreme than what we actually
experienced um and
i guess i guess my broader point here is
even if we accept that these aren't
predictions
if this is if these models are presented
in the way that they are um
showing you know potentially
catastrophic hospitalization and death
figures really tragic stuff and it
doesn't end up anywhere near that level
doesn't that undermine the trust that we
hopefully would have in bodies like sage
and spy m to be able to model this not
just for kobe but for future pandemics
i mean i still
i still dispute the fact that the models
in december were all over estimating
numbers of deaths because they
absolutely weren't but i agree with you
some of them were
um
it's key it's it's clear that um
i mean some of our modelling that in
december had much much lower numbers for
example so i i know it's true because we
did it
but so it's it's obviously clear that
communication is really key i mean most
of the time
we spend modeling and so we don't really
have a lot of time to work on
communication and to how ready to use
the
to use the numbers and use the curves
that come out
i'm absolutely not saying that all
models are right i don't think that at
all what i think is that they're a tool
for understanding
um for understanding the data that we're
seeing and for understanding how things
might interact
and
often it's looking at
even if you're not looking at the
absolute numbers you're looking at the
relative impact of different
interventions and different
interventions at different times
and they're often quite robust to
absolute levels levels of infection so
it's really a question of how these
models are used
um
i mean um
well let me let me to
to wrap up let me let me ask you a
question about your experience on spy m
throughout the cove pandemic
if we're thinking in the future to to
other pandemics a horrifying thought but
one i think is very much on people's
minds now seeing as what we've been
through over the past two years
something we have to prepare for
what do you think spy m and sage really
got right and what would you do
differently if another pandemic were to
emerge
um
well
i mean the way spiem and sage has
functioned has changed over the last two
years as well
for example it's considerably
larger than it used to be
and in in my opinion having that
plurality of models having that
uncertainty
is is really important and i think for a
future pandemic
uh we'd want to start with
that
that those plurality of models so we're
not just relying on one or two models to
to provide evidence for policy
um
i think the
question of communication and how
documents are written often the
documents we write are quite technical
and
not intended for public can
communication
and that could i think that could be
definitely something that would be
improved
certainly
well thank you so much for joining us
spectator tv this has been a fascinating
conversation
and finally is drinking in the office
really all that bad can actually help to
bring a team together i'm joined now by
rory sutherland the spectator's wikiman
columnist
rory thank you for joining spectator tv
now in your column for the magazine this
week you have discussed
workplace drinking a topical subject at
the moment are you for or against
i suppose i'm not necessarily
comfortable with what went on in downing
street by any means but i'm not quite
comfortable either with the way in which
it's reported
as though any consumption of alcohol in
the workplace
necessarily means that there's a party
going on
and that it's somehow an egregious
activity
and the reason i'd say that in
particular is much of this reporting
most of it in fact is being done by
journalists who are hardly completely
innocent on the question of workplace
drinking
themselves and
all i can say is it's complicated i
would like a more forensic investigation
of what went on i would regard music
dancing that kind of party thing as
wholly unacceptable not necessarily
because it's illegal but because it's in
bad faith
on the other hand i don't regard it as
acceptable if you take that photograph
of the downing street garden taken from
an upper window
i don't regard that as having any
evidential value whatsoever it shows
some people in a garden
the purpose of the legislation was to
prevent people mixing with strangers
those people were not strangers to each
other they were in a secure space they'd
chosen to go outside which in
terms of epidemiological behavior was
probably a sensible thing to do and one
or two of them were consuming wine
now
i don't quite think it's fair
for that to be used to rile the populace
i accept the fact that ninety percent of
people are rarely if ever allowed to
drink in the workplace
on the other hand there are plenty of
cultures including by the way medicine
where quite a lot of valuable
information transmission takes place by
people drinking together after work
in businesses where you're not paid
overtime there's a kind of informal
exchange where you stay a little bit
late you do some work you talk about
work you enjoy a drink
now the culture will vary just as
drinking culture varies massively from
country to country i mean the last two
or three presidents of the united states
have been t total for example
okay
it varies enormously from one workplace
to another yes i'm completely open to
the argument that political culture is
far too boozy i work in advertising and
i think the same thing myself i think
it's obsessively gregarious dominated by
kind of fomo and absolutely obsessed
uh with attending endless drinks parties
i don't think that's healthy
at the same time i don't think it's
entirely fair to vilify the behavior
completely
for one thing people working very very
hard at conditions of some personal risk
are entitled to winds down briefly from
time to time
isn't the explosive issue here that we
were not under normal conditions in fact
the police were being sent after people
who were daring to have somebody into
their garden have somebody into their
home even have somebody into their
office that wasn't a necessary
work event it isn't the issue that some
people in number 10 decided to have some
wine at the end of the day is that they
explicitly made it against the rules for
anybody else to do so
the reason i mean this this comes down
to an interesting thing which is to what
extent you practice deontology
and to what extent you practice
consequentialism okay now the reason
parties were banned was not because they
uh allowed for the consumption of
alcohol nothing about the legislation
said anything about what you did in your
own home you could be completely sozzled
the entire time under lockdown if
conditions allowed the purpose for
banning
probably by yourself if you were living
on your really led to mixing okay
now if these people are already mixing
they're in a household
if you had spent at a lockdown living
alone undoubtedly those conditions were
much much tougher on you than if you
lived in an ashram or a commune
i wouldn't be surprised to hear that for
example the staff of windsor castle or
the staff of buckingham palace had
drinks together during lockdown because
they occupied the same space
okay the purpose of the law was not to
prevent people having as good a time as
was feasibly possible under the
circumstances it was to prevent people
becoming exposed to additional people
other than those to whom they
necessarily had to be in contact with
and so i think there's something we have
the rule of law for a reason
um and you might argue that the
conditions in a workplace once you have
determined that these people have to
interact in an office
okay
effectively mean that it isn't relevant
to prevent people drinking wine with
people with whom they're already
communing
now i i
okay i get the fact that it seems unfair
but then so much of this was monstrously
unfair it's not just that it was a bit
unfair or a bit annoying or a bit lonely
or a bit sad that people had to
basically stay inside and not see other
people i don't remember the guidance
coming out from number 10 saying
actually it's fine if you go out into
the park with a bunch of your friends or
a bunch of your family and socialize
because we know from a health and safety
perspective now that this virus doesn't
really transmit outside in fact that
weekend they had the police tweeting out
do not break the rules essentially do
not enjoy the good weather with your
mates make sure that you abide by the
law and this isn't an issue of drinking
it's not an issue of having a bit of fun
which i agree rory can be a great time
of course under the appropriate
circumstances it's the fact that the
people who were making these laws have
been found to have been breaking them
and they didn't update the laws for
everybody else so it wasn't as if people
could enjoy these good times as well
um well other people couldn't enjoy the
fact if it involved meeting other people
although on the very same day the
beaches were fairly crowded let's be
honest okay it wasn't as if the public
were being entirely uh obedient outdoors
i've already written a piece in the
spectator which explained why garden
parties
had to be banned even when it was known
that outdoor transmission was
comparatively rare which is the simple
fact that an outdoor garden party turns
into an indoor party
that's what tends to happen towards the
end of the evening when it gets cold
when people need to leave the loo in
this case
if these people were not meeting anybody
new if they'd invited people from
adjacent buildings absolutely clear
that's an absolutely clear breach of the
rules here it's a little more ambiguous
the second question to ask is not
necessarily about whether it's good or
bad but whether this deserves the volume
of media attention that it's getting
and it strikes me to some extent that we
don't actually need the metaverse
because the media already creates it for
us a kind of parallel reality where
attention is paid to things to the
extent to which it suits a pre-ordained
narrative
and i don't think the record by the way
of journalism here is all that great
robert cialdini does a lot of work which
shows that most media bias is not the
result of a biased depiction of opinions
it's the relative prominence that is
given to different stories that's the
greater vehicle of media bias okay
now you can imagine a world in which a
blair regime or another regime to whom
journalists were better disposed had
committed the same infractions where
this would have received much less
attention would have ended up on page
five
okay i don't think this is an area which
necessarily should be dominating the
news cycle when you have you know a
potential invasion of ukraine on the
cards
okay and there's something about the
incessant attention given to the story
which doesn't seem to me entirely in
proportion to the infractions committed
well rory after that discussion i think
you've earned yourself a drink thanks
for joining spectator tv
and that's it for this week if you've
enjoyed this episode don't forget to
subscribe to the spectator's youtube
channel just click the subscribe button
at the bottom of this video and tap the
bell icon to make sure you never miss an
episode thanks for watching and do join
us again next week
[Music]
you